hello
everyone and welcome back to book club
uh this is the final book club we have
for the infinite game where's my copy
it's somewhere around here
the infinite game um so i'm a little sad
but as you all know we added a
spontaneous
additional book club for together
is better which we're going to do
on the 21st august 21st
same time 1pm eastern um
and uh so it'll give you two weeks to
read together is better
um and uh it's a lovely little book and
we can do that because quite frankly if
i'm honest
i didn't understand because it's like
the highlight of my week um we are live
on linkedin facebook
youtube and twitter we have people
coming in from around the world really
exciting hello scottsdale
arizona hello cutter hello new york uh
hello ethiopia
uh uh india um
australia man you're up early in the
morning uk colombia man this always
blows my mind
arizona um philippines
i've eaten balut well i tried to then i
got a little bit grossed out and i
didn't eat it um
uh it's so i i just love how we're all
here together south africa west virginia
turkey
uh the netherlands uh just such a
fantastic
uh grouping of everyone um
as everyone knows book club is not about
reading a book
it is about coming together and doing
something with each other so i hope
you've
enjoyed it and enjoyed the conversations
um thanks for sending in your questions
we're going to be going through two
things today
chapters 10 and 11 of course a little
bit at the end uh which is existential
flexibility and the
courage to lead so um i thought i would
have a little special guest today
um are we good on special guests we're
good and special guest yes
okay i'm gonna assume we are i don't
know um so hopefully this will work
um an organization that has publicly
stated
that they want to be infinite minded
which is airbnb the ceo of airbnb brian
chesky
um a short while ago about over a year
ago actually
he made a public announcement that he
wants his company to be
infinite minded so i thought what an
opportunity to talk to brian
um uh and ask him how he found the
courage
to buck the system so i think let's get
brian in here and have a little chat
with him about
courage to lead an existential
flexibility hey there he is brian how
are you how are you doing good to see
you
back today thank you so much for that
yes long time to talk
good to see you it's good to see you too
um i know you guys been going through
uh some very hard times uh one thing
which i don't think people realize
you know you're in the travel industry
you're you you your business lost eighty
percent
of its revenue in eight weeks which is
just astonishing um
and unfortunately you had to make some
really difficult decisions
and ask some people to transition away
what i love about you and i just have to
say this
is i use your company as the blueprint
for other companies that are struggling
on how to treat people with dignity in
this hard time you were generous with
people my favorite thing is you set up
an entire website
was it airbnb.com talent yeah and with
500
000 people so yeah i thought we
basically told employees um
so i'll just jump in but like so many
people they think
um they do three things they try to give
severands and
you know sometimes they they they go
they give
they don't quite go as far as they could
and you gotta go as far as you can
the way they communicate they hold back
like they either don't give them all the
information
or they just kind of hold their emotions
back no one wants to see that like you
want to know leaders have a heart
because
that tells you they care about you and
you're going to be okay but the last
thing is we thought there's something
that doesn't cost a lot of money
we can do what we can to help them get
jobs
and my co-founder joe had a great idea
he said what if we took our recruiting
team and we
made them like equivalent of a job
placement helping uh people leaving
and then we took it a step further and
we said what if
we allowed everyone to opt in to post
their profiles so recruiters can contact
them
500 000 people eventually contacted them
it's unbelievable i know we
we we were looking for some help and we
went to airbnb.com
talent and we reached out to someone and
they'd already found a job so
it was fantastic i just love that you
you did it with dignity and that's the
most important thing
the thing i wanted to talk to you about
was some time ago you made a very public
announcement
um that you wanted airbnb to be an
infinite minded organization
um which is a big deal i've had
conversations with ceos behind the
scenes where they've expressed interest
but
nobody does it publicly all the
pressures on businesses these days are
to be finite minded
from your investors from marketplace
sometimes even internally
and uh you're not public now but if you
ever do
the pressure becomes even more
overwhelming right you finite minded how
did you
find the courage to basically buck the
system uh
and and make this public announcement of
the kind of company you want to build
i just kind of started with a couple
maybe three realizations
the first is the companies i admired um
they they were enduring companies you
know like i don't know
like apple you know or disney or you
name the company
um the second is when you're a founder
and you start a company
i mean i don't have children but you
know
you know it is like your baby the last
thing you want to do is outlive your
child
and the third thing is like like
if you have a purpose you have to ask
yourself well like i guess it's okay to
be finite minded if you have a purpose
and that purpose you achieve
but if if that purpose is an ideal that
you're constantly pursuing
then at some point if you don't keep
pursuing it it doesn't happen
and i felt like the thing that we were
doing or the thing we're trying to do
is try to you know bring people together
connect them so they can feel like they
belong
i just think they're so i think that's
something that people are yearning for
now more than ever and we have not even
scratched the surface
and then you know you and i talked and
um
you you you'd obviously you said what
you've written in the book
and i always thought to myself you know
it's really weird that
we we cover business the way we cover
sports
like who's winning who's losing uh by
the way a lot of the same people who
like the stock market like sports and so
i understand why
the stock market and sports business and
sports seem similar
they're not similar at all i mean even
this idea of competition i mean
competition exists
but in the technology industry one of
the things we learn is that you're not
all fighting for the same pie the whole
point of technology is to grow pies
that's
kind of what this industry does for the
most part and so you used to tell me
like
it's not about like winning or losing
it's about being ahead or being behind
and we have the most unbelievable
examples of companies that seem like
they were in the brink and they're now
and so i don't actually think it took a
lot of it didn't take a lot of courage
for me
um it just took logic well i i
appreciate that you followed that logic
i mean it's
i think you're you're underselling
yourself that logic is clear to a lot of
ceos
but they shrug their shoulders and say
it's the system or what am i supposed to
do or
you know i i wish i could change it so
so
what i love is you're a young company
with young leadership
who who is saying the future of business
has to be different and you're and
you're taking the lead so i
i appreciate your your position so much
i don't think it's as hard as
like it seems really scary to like kind
of go out on a limb at first
but the thing is that actually like like
who the hell it wants to cheer on
companies
like just like it's like driving their
car at the edge of a constant cliff like
who wants to do that we and do we really
want to live in a world with all kinds
of company like
i actually think there's a lot of
support for an idea of a company just
enduring like
when when did that become controversial
it's such a good point as you've as you
after you made the announcement
and you've been making the decisions to
be more infinite minded
um were there some things that were
easier than you expected and were there
some things that were bigger challenges
than you except
expected yeah um
what was easy was for everyone to say
they agreed with it because it seems
like almost impossible to disagree with
the concept
like well if you don't agree that you
want to
have like a kind of intimate or enduring
time rise and you're saying yeah i want
the music to stop well who wants to say
that
the hard part is actually changing how
you do things
yeah yeah i want to be infinite i want
to like make the real better place i
want to do the right thing
now let's still do these 10 things the
way they've always been done yeah
and so i think what gets very very hard
is to say change the score card
about what success is because if you say
something
and you talk a certain way you got to
start walking that certain way yeah
it means that like you know how you run
your board meetings like what metrics
you have who's on your board
and like the things you pursue like they
all have to change
and the moment you start changing
mechanisms that's when you start to
really
feel some of the you start to feel like
feel that right yeah it's the tangible
actions
yeah one of the other ways people
actually agree with you
not when you say something but when you
try to do something right
right that that ain't that the truth
ain't that the truth um
uh also uh when covert hit
um you know we're talking about
existential flexibility uh this week
um a lot of organizations were forced to
pivot and some
struggled they they were just grasping
for straws double downing on their old
business models
and and they put themselves at the
center of the equation how are we going
to survive how are we going to make more
money those are the companies that
struggle to pivot
airbnb pivoted reasonably quickly
producing these live online experiences
um can you sort of walk us through sort
of how that decision was made
uh i i assume you you fell back on your
just cause you fell back on
on that ideal that you have and you just
found a new way to do it just
talk about how that how it happened and
how quickly it happened well first of
all
it starts with knowing what what
business you're in
and our we're not in we're not we didn't
start this company
to be a travel company we didn't start
this company get into real estate
joey and i started this company because
we're deeply passionate about connecting
people
and belonging and so when you do that
you say well there's many ways to
connect you think we
invented all the ways that people could
connect of course we hadn't
so you start with that the second thing
you do is you just have to have a
mindset
you know andy grove um one of the
founders of intel and he said
uh bad companies are destroyed by a
crisis good company survive account
racist but great companies are defined
by a crisis
i want us to be that third bucket and
you know what so much of its mindset
if you think you're going to win if you
think that this is going to define you
in a positive way and you're going to
learn something from it and it's going
to make you stronger
it kind of happens right like so much of
your mindset of the leader becomes the
psychology the organization
and that psychology really becomes a
collective consciousness that
mana it it becomes real and so
so that was the thing and we said every
single opportunity is a moment we have
to pivot move
fast so what actually happened was
first of all you have to have the
mindset a mindset of hope of optimism of
resiliency that we're going to get
through this and now we're going to get
through this but every one of these
crisis
is going to lead to a new point of
innovation let's look for moments
and a moment happen we uh with social
distancing we had to shut down in person
experiences everybody's known for homes
but we also
have three-hour activities that you can
book with people all over the world do
really cool activities
they got paused suddenly you know we
started doing listening sessions with
our host it's important by the way to
listen
and be curious and some of the
you know i don't think it's much in life
you have to have ideas
as much as be a receiver for ideas like
it's not my job to have an idea and it's
not our job for any of us having ideas i
think we need to be receivers we're like
radio antennas like we just gotta
get on the right signal and and they'll
tell you people will tell you things
and people told us they want to host um
but they can't do it in person can they
offer them online
at first i thought to myself no you
can't offer them
online we're about connection and
connections in the real world then i
thought to myself
well that's the case there's not going
to be a lot of connection anytime soon
so i quickly realized and we quickly
realized yeah we should get in on this
and um within 14 days we pivoted
the entire product line to offer online
experiences so now you can do we have
800 experiences
200 olympians so we did a nine-year
partial olympia with the olympics
200 olympians including jackie joyner
kersey you may remember from the 9th
sure olympics and and then we had um
tony hawk didn't experience
um so they did these like activities and
you actually can meet them and go on
kind of remotely be on experience with
them and so we did that but i think so
much of it as
turning on a dime i never wanted to just
be focused on survival
if you focus survival that's probably
all you're going to get and so i said i
don't want to focus on survival and so
while
all these other companies i saw were
like kind of
you know like just shuttering their
businesses and just in defensive mode
and preservation mode
i think preservation mode is a very
dangerous place to be
and i think the more resources the
company accumulates
the more they start worrying about
losing things like a parent with an
overactive amygdala
worrying if the child is gonna like and
putting the helmet on the child before
they go outside you're worried
something's gonna happen and some point
they never live their life
right you gotta like the same thing with
a company you
yeah you got to be like concerned but
not so concerned
that you protect the company from itself
and you're afraid to do anything
and you're just preserving resources and
and actually that's the worst
possible thing ironically for
shareholders right shareholders need the
company to grow
right so this weird like obsession
sometimes um that some people have with
serving shareholders
it's not actually it's not it's not in
the shareholders best interest
they need companies to create value and
therefore they need to be focused
on doing new things people love that's
what needs to happen to create value
i love it brian i i know your day is
back to back today i am so grateful
that you took time to stop in with us
and show us what courage to lead and
what existential flexibility looks like
in the real world
uh such a pleasure such an honor thanks
so much for taking the time oh thank you
simon
well that was a treat for me i gotta
tell ya you know to to
somebody working at the scale of airbnb
to hear what goes through his mind
uh and how he thinks about his business
you understand that existential
flexibility
for and and i wrote about it but what
fun to hear it uh and by the way
uh uh i didn't know what he was gonna
say
uh so uh but so much fun to hear that
when we talk about existential
flexibility for the leader who makes
that existential flex
they actually think the risk is not
flexing he actually said it wasn't that
hard
for the for the rest of the world who's
afraid to make those flexes it seems
crazy
but for the leader that actually makes
that flex they actually see the greater
risk
in not blowing things up they see the
greater risk of not flexing
um and and i so appreciate um even
his his statement of courage um you know
he's i think he's he's humble about it
um but uh how he he he resorted to
listening and we've talked about that a
few times
throughout this book um which is you
don't have to
if you're the leader you don't have to
have all the ideas and i think too many
leaders think that they have to solve
all the problems and
and they didn't um they didn't actually
come up with the basis of the idea
of these live online experiences they
thought it wasn't possible you heard him
say it he's
when when the host came and said we want
to do this he said well you can't
it's impossible but what they did was
they listened they heard what people
wanted to do and they simply pivoted
their business to provide that platform
um my expectation i would i would i
expect to happen
i don't know this i haven't talked to
brian about it but what i expect what
will happen
which is once we go back to somewhat of
a normal world where we can travel again
that that airbnb will probably have a
blended business they'll probably have
both i don't think this will be
something they abandoned i mean
and i think that's the sign of a good
existential flex that you're not doing
it to simply put a band-aid on the times
but rather you found a new way to market
and a new way to
spread value we've certainly gone
through this ourselves you know
we couldn't rely on live events anymore
we now have our live online classes and
i can guarantee you
it's here to stay um we think it's
actually a wonderful way to spread the
message
um so very grateful to brian thank you
very very much for joining us
that was really wonderful um let's take
some questions from the
outside world from everywhere ohio
has won um here's one from rubix
rubix asked me what happened to the open
playbook man you've been following my
stuff for a long time
thank you rubix back in the early days
when i was first experimenting
and talking about the infinite game and
the principles of the infinite game
and developing an infinite mindset i
used to talk about having an open
playbook
um uh but as many of you who
who follow my work may know um i think i
do all my thinking out loud
so if you go back and look at early
versions of everything you'll see me
trying to work through the ideas and
work out the ideas
and sometimes i develop and then and
they grow and change
and so i realized open playbook was
actually not quite accurate it wasn't
just this open-mindedness
and that's when i changed the term and
somewhat of the definition of an open
playbook to existential flexibility
um i think it's because it was more
profound and more robust than what i was
a tinkering with
with open playbook but rubik's gold star
for
for for catching that i absolutely love
that hello saudi arabia scotland
uh montevideo amazing iran
um uh lovely to see you all okay let's
do some more questions
uh we have a question here from get your
flex on book club
love it from nancy bertulli
um how do we know when it is time to
make an existential flex
and how do we find the courage to bet
the farm um
so how do you know when you when it's
time to make an existential flex
so existential flexes happen when
there's
political changes technological changes
cultural changes
and we realize that our business and
whatever we're selling whatever we're
offering sometimes our culture
is actually if we if we if we follow out
the logic
not viable um and you you read about the
example of kodak
um the invention of the digital camera
you know
the the engineer who developed the
digital camera who invented the digital
camera for kodak back in the mid-1970s
that's how old that technology is
um he said in 10 or 20 years there'll be
no
no film cameras you can just follow the
logic um
and it was the senior leadership who
chose to put blinders on
and so uh uh any customer focused
uh vision focused er just cause focus
leader it's kind of obvious quite
frankly
um i mean it was if you go back to the
example i gave of steve jobs and apple
pivoting to the the graphic user
interface
you know an organization that's obsessed
with making things simple to use for a
customer the technology is out of the
bag they didn't invent it
but they could they could you could
follow the logic that that this thing is
easier and better than having to learn
an entire computer language to use a
personal computer
and so why not be uh on the front of the
wave rather than the back of the wave
um so i think for if you have a good
just cause
um if you have a clear sense of vision
of where you want the organization to
go and what you're trying to advance i i
mean i i can't i wish i could give you a
better answer
it's kind of obvious you know the and
and you have discussions with your with
with
your people in your company and it's
kind of obvious to everybody
because we're all vision focused on the
vision and then so when you find the
courage
you sort of turn around to the people to
the left of you and turn to the right of
you like you know we're gonna have to do
this yeah i know we're gonna have to do
this
you know it's gonna hurt us in the short
term yeah i know it's gonna hurt us in
the short term do you think we should do
this
yeah i think we should do this and you
do it the courage comes from checking
with the people to the left and checking
with the people to the right
and everybody goes this is way more
exciting and what you often find
is that when the change is made that's
it's like it's kind of like it's kind of
like jumping off a high dive
right the hard part isn't the falling
into the water the hard part is just the
initial little leap of faith a little
jump
so once the decision is made actually
the excitement kicks in
um and and that's sort of a remarkable
thing you would think would be fear and
but it's actually not once somebody
makes the decision the excitement kicks
in that's definitely been the case at
airbnb once they made the decision
the excitement went up from internal and
from hosts uh
good question uh sarah hembree
how are you from tallahassee florida
she asks uh our book club is primarily
middle and high school teachers
along with parents and community members
uh along with parents and community
members
education the epitome of what could be
the infinite game is a pivotal moment
right now
yes it is if small pockets of schools
and leaders take the chance to shift the
idea of purpose of education
can their existential flex impact the
larger national system with
uh which focuses more on finite goals
amen amen amen
it was just what brian said uh he was
quoting andy grove the founder of intel
which is for bad companies a crisis will
destroy them i don't remember the exact
quote
for good companies uh something else and
for great companies
they'll reinvent and i think uh never
let a good crisis go to waste
um and uh one of the things that i think
has
is forced education to do in this crisis
is look at how it teaches of course
education is an infinite game school is
finite but education should be last
should last our entire lives i would
hate to
think that people think their learning
is done when they graduate high school
or college
um uh and i think it's forced uh
uh it's kind of like what happened when
the internet showed up
uh in publishing or in movies which is
it forces you to look inward and say
what actually do we do um and how do we
do it
and i think that that schools have
mixed bag and whether they've really
properly embraced
uh online and simply transferring all
the classes to online i mean that that's
not it either
but it's some sort of this blended model
and i think the more forward-thinking
school districts
are sitting down and saying okay the
world has changed we have to equip
young people to be productive members of
society and teach them basic skills and
give them a basic education so that they
can
survive given that the world is the way
it is
if we were starting a school from
scratch day if we were a startup
if we said okay we're starting a school
from scratch how would we build our
school
for this marketplace and i think to
reinvent oneself
to for for schools to reinvent
themselves it's an amazing opportunity
and i think because of the structure of
school and the the standardized tests
and the short-term metrics
i think that opportunity really didn't
exist in the past it was just
just you couldn't do it unless you were
a private school but i think that for
all schools public private and otherwise
um it's an amazing amazing opportunity
now to actually re-imagine what
education could look like
into the 21st century um i hope those
conversations are happening and just
like brian explained
invite outsiders invite students and
imma and to reimagine what school could
look like um
take information in doesn't mean you
have to do what they say but it means
you get to take in all the new ideas
and something may spark some inspiration
um i'll add one editorial piece
i think one things that all schools
should be doing and could be doing
um is building leadership education in
for their students and leadership
education in for their teachers and
administrators uh people go into
administration
they go into leadership and nobody
teaches them how to lead um we should be
teaching listening skills to students we
should be teaching effective
confrontation to students we should be
dealing
with teaching how to deal with stress to
students these are skills that they
have to deal with in the in the future
world and they are not being prepared
for them
um i'd rather see that happen than
calculus
uh by the way speaking from a
non-mathematician you're getting a lot
of questions
sorry i'm getting questions about what
my t-shirt is it's just it's a
it's a japanese print i like japanese
stuff
um i saw it on uniqlo it was on sale so
i got it
um uh okay
how do we put these ideas into a company
that isn't flexible
so the most common question i used to
get was what about these millennials
and i did a thing i did a video and
answered that and that question went
away which is kind of good
the most common question that i get now
every single time the most common
question is
what if i believe in the infinite
mindset and senior leadership
is so finite minded how do i how do i
what do i do
um well if we adjust to an infinite
mindset we accept
that um a we can affect we can't change
people
right we can only change our own
behavior we can't force senior
leadership to change especially if we
have no direct contact with them
but we can choose to become the leaders
we wish we had right
so the whole idea is say is to is to
work within the system you've got of
course
but to say okay we're going to build an
infinite minded team and so
amongst the people you work with and it
doesn't matter if you're in a leadership
position or not remember leadership has
nothing to do with rank
leadership is the responsibility to take
care of those around us so
you can take care of your boss too hey
boss you okay during this cobit how are
you um
um and start embracing those uh those
practices
you know if the organization doesn't
have a good just cause tell your team
what your just causes
and say why you love this job and how
this job is helping you advance your
just cause
start building trusting teams start
making the people you work with
feel like someone has their back that
someone cares about them as human beings
that you create a space where they can
be open and honest without judgment
um uh you study your worthy rivals
so that you can be a better leader but
also
ask the team what other teams inside the
company are better than we are
so that at certain things so that we can
become an even better
team not because we want to beat them
but because we want to improve build
that sense
of constant improvement into the team um
be willing to change certain things
you know very often companies do things
because that's the way they've always
been done
but nobody's ever asked does it have to
be done this way and nobody ever asks
can i change it
and very often the answer is we don't
know why it's done this way and yes you
can change it
ask the questions i tell you one quick
funny story as a side about asking
questions
long ago when i had a job uh i worked at
a large
ad agency and it was a fairly common
experience where
my boss would come into my office and
say the client wants this by wednesday
get it done i'd be like it's impossible
to get this done by wednesday
and he would say i don't know what to
tell you you have to get the client
wants it by wednesday
so one day i called the client
and i said hey i got this thing that you
asked for when do you need it by
uh because they said you have to have it
by wednesday and they went no i can have
it by friday or monday that's totally
fine
it's because somebody said when do you
want it they said wednesday and
we went okay and then it became the
point is ask a question
sometimes we have more flexibility and
more freedom than we think we do
and then what ends up happening is you
build this wonderful high-performing
team
if you have an open-minded group of
leaders even if they're finite-minded
they're going to look at what you're
doing in your high-performing team with
higher loyalty better relationships and
they're going to say
what are you guys doing down there and
they may want to learn from you
if they're completely just you know in
their own world and short-term
metric-driven
um they'll just leave you alone because
you're high-performing
um and eventually some of the people
will leave that group and go join other
teams they'll either move on or get
promoted out
and they'll bring everything they've
learned and they'll take it to those
teams and they'll build
high-performing infinite-minded teams
and eventually the tail wags the dog
unfortunately we don't know how long it
takes depends on the organization
depends on the culture depends on the
people
but the tail can wag the dog i saw it
happen with a hundred thousand person
organization
and it took two years which i think is
unbelievably quickly
and it was completely without senior
leadership's help we saw the whole
organization
pivot just because the people started to
embrace new ideas
uh sarah nicola the raf girls from
swindon
how are you uh you've mentioned some
small companies
that have made an existential flex in
response to covid
uh what major companies do you think
have managed it
uh and who are the ones who are truly
playing the infinite game
um i think that well we heard from
airbnb i mean i think that is a great
example of a very large company and
even despite the fact that for very
practical
and unfortunate reasons realistic
reasons survivable ex
literally existential reasons they've
had to ask some people to transition off
they've done it in a way that um as we
talked about with great dignity
um other big companies i was you know i
was quite impressed
by nike in the early days of covid they
were like the first company that started
redefining um uh
being at home and talking about how we
can still be athletes at home
i was pretty impressed by that in terms
of uh what other big companies have
have made a good pivot that's a great
question
nothing comes to mind off the top of my
head i will
post something i think that's a good
question about big companies
the problem is is that big companies
especially public companies
they they struggle to pivot and maybe
one of the reasons i'm struggling to
that something i'm struggling to have
something come to mind immediately
is because it's probably few and far
between what tends to happen with large
companies
is they tend to knuckle down they tend
to double down on
on the old or wait it out or try and
just cut expenses
i think i think television and movies
are
they were a little late to the game in
the pivot but i think we're starting to
see it there they're starting to learn
how to adjust things are becoming
smaller and more efficient
they're realizing they can make things
from a distance which they never thought
were possible
so i think we're starting to see a
little a little bit of that um
what's that okay
um moving on
uh my question is how do you manage
employee motivation during this period
somebody asked me about sorry i'm gonna
interrupt somebody asked me about
netflix
i don't think netflix pivoted i think
netflix
their business just works really well
for the time we're in
i mean it's you know i'm not sure they
actually did they do they really can
profoundly change the course of their
business uh i don't think so i just
think that uh
kind of like amazon uh it's like boy
boy does your business benefit from from
this day and age so i think that was
just
good luck quite frankly um sorry
sorry sarah what was the question um
from amit yes how do you manage
motivation during this period
how do we manage employee motivation in
such a period of uncertainty
um we have to remember that we're all
human beings and we're going through
trauma
and so if you had a friend i should
assume everybody here has at least one
friend you're in a book club so i know
you have at least one
um uh what would you do for a friend um
we have to ex we have to
accept that everyone will go through the
trauma of covet everyone there will be
no avoiding it there will be no
compartmentalizing it
some people go through it early some
people go through it late some people it
will linger some people it will go
quickly some people will
be recurring but we're all going through
some sort of trauma
and just to know that somebody is there
to care for us
um the most that's the most important
thing if somebody's performance is down
or you see them looking a little bit
despondent or a little bit quiet on on
on a zoom
call on a meeting um immediately just
pick up the phone
when that meeting is done and be like
hey you were a little bit quieter they
just want to check in on you make sure
you're okay
don't expect them to come and open up to
you and and all of a sudden you're going
to become their therapist
um you know and if they don't open up to
you it's fine
the most important thing is that they
know that you care and they know that
you're there
um and just keep doing that you know
motivation is going to go up and down it
has for me
it has for everybody on this call it's
gonna go up and down
and uh you know it's a delicate balance
of needing to
to to continue to to um
give people the tools they need and help
support them so they can do a good job
but if we see a little step back that it
doesn't mean that they're a problem that
means they have a problem
and so this is where good leadership
it's it's like good parenting
you know sometimes you yell at a kid and
sometimes you don't
sometimes you sit down with me like hey
what's on your mind and it's knowing to
recognize the signs and that find that
delicate balance
um and and and the motivation will come
and go
then what we want to do is keep them
inspired uh the motivation will come and
go so that is
normal that's the other thing it's
normal
nothing is abnormal here because it's a
weird time
um here's one that i love um
so we got a note from uh two book clubs
that
are frequent uh attendees and have been
from from the start with y days
uh the no stress book club and the
international uh
and they identified each other as worthy
rivals which i really love
um and what they decided to do is choose
to form a partnership they've actually
joined book clubs they've actually now
coordinate together
i love that here's the question they
asked uh from ashley freeman and
uh ying pan uh from the two book clubs
respectively
um for those of us who work in strongly
finite uh minded organizations
who want to take up your just cause for
more inspired and fulfilled world what
initial steps would you advise we take
so that eventually the tail wags a dog
well we talked about this a little bit
uh before commit yourself to the path of
constant improvement i think that is
such an
important thing um uh you can
this is the funny thing we have more
freedom than we think we have you can
actually invent your own metrics
now they don't have to be formal metrics
but you can actually invent your own
metrics so for example if all of the
metrics inside our organization are
finite and short term
we can within our own little team we can
create um
uh the person the person we all want to
be more like
a award and we can all write essays and
who we nominate
and within our team we can recognize the
person we want to be more like
so and we can give them a little statue
and say we all want to be more like you
because you embody the values
um that that we believe in um and
and we can do little things we can we
can create little subcultures
um where we're embracing all the
concepts of the infinite of the infinite
minded
organization um so yeah you just do it
on smaller scale
um hello yorkshire
um um
given the current pandemic situation how
do you maintain focus
on and ignore the distractions given the
current pandemic situation how do we
stay
focused ignore the distractions um
i mean turning off the news is probably
a good idea
um you know one of the things we have to
be aware of is is to try to divide your
mind i know it sounds silly
but this is what i've tried to do which
is you know i mean two
i mean i try to maintain two mindsets
which is mindset one is i'm going to be
informed
i want to be informed i'm going to turn
on the fire hose
that is the news and everybody with an
opinion um
and i'm going to sort of take it in and
listen to some of it take some of it
with a grain of salt try and find middle
grounds
i also i've i'm i i
listen to news from both sides of the
political spectrum
i want to know how it's been reported on
both sides and i sort of
find something in the middle i have my
favorite news sources i like the bbc
because they're non-commercial uh uh
i like non-commercial news um um
and that's sort of one side and then i
have sort of okay what we're trying to
do in advance our own cause
um and that's where you sort of you
remain stubbornly focused on
on why you're doing what you're doing
the cause that you're trying to advance
and asking ourselves our own difficult
questions um the worst thing that we can
do
is is keep changing our mind on a daily
basis because the news cycle is changing
or because there's new information
and this sort of whiplash creates
uncertainty and uncertainty is very
unnerving for human beings we can deal
with good news we can even deal with bad
news
it's uncertainty that is just absolutely
stress creating for human beings when i
don't know what's going to happen
that's where stress sets in if
something's bad
this is what you know this is you know
when we put people through
known stress like here's existential
flexibility we're going to make a flex
everyone's like all right we can figure
this out
even covid when covet happened what we
wanted our leaders to say
was this is bad we're going to give you
the the most current information we have
we're going to keep updating it some of
it we're going to get wrong some of it
we're going to
keep you posted no one knows everything
because this is entirely new but we're
going to try and give you as much
information
oh and by the way this is our long-term
goal get people healthy
make sure that it's safe open an economy
making sure that it's done in a
responsible way and we're going to try
and do those things as quickly as we can
but we're going to keep you posted
because we're not going to sacrifice
either
for fear of making it worse that's all
we needed we needed somebody to tell us
that we've got a long-term plan
and then just keep us informed and what
they know it's the whiplash
and the constant you know the sides
fighting with each other but what's
right and wrong
which is creating unbelievable
uncertainty for us we don't know who to
believe or what to believe
and so what does that do it increases
stress and so
what we need at work is some sort of
certainty we need our leaders to give us
some sort of vision some sort of
direction
this is our cause our cause has not
changed how we're going to advance our
cause has changed because of covid
but the cause itself remains fixed
we need something fixed to make us feel
inspired
uh what else we have here
uh do a few more questions um
okay you know what i want to do i never
do this but there were some
there were some things that i was
reading in this chapter that i wanted to
actually highlight because i thought
they were actually kind of interesting
[Music]
right at the beginning of existential
flexibility page 186 if you're reading
along
this is what i wrote existential flex
does not happen at the founding of the
company it happens when the company is
fully formed and functioning to all
finite minded is observant it is
existential because
okay we talked about that the point is
because it's not about
uh uh and i even said it it's not about
the energy at a startup time it's
recreating startup energy
when the organization is fully
functional and so
for organizations that are successful in
their existential flex
there should be a lot of excitement
because just like a startup
why is a st why is the energy in a
startup so exciting because we have no
resources
all we have is vision and we have each
other and that's the excitement
well with existential flex you're
recreating that kind of energy
midstream which means you need vision
that outstrips your resources
and you need people who who care about
that vision and who are in it for the
for the for the wild ride and so there
should be high morale
in the middle of an existential flex um
we're going through our own
and i'm watching it it's really kind of
amazing to write about something
theoretically
and then be in the middle of it and as
we go through hours it's been really
kind of amazing to watch
the uh morale stay high on our team as
well
i also wrote on page 200 so how do we
find the courage
uh to change our mindset number one we
can wait for a life-altering experience
that shakes us to our core and
challenges the way we see the world
well congratulations we all got one um
you know i said that was something we
couldn't rely on because it was so
uncertain but literally the whole world
has been shaken um and so again amazing
opportunity to change our mindset
amazing opportunity for experimentation
okay let's do another question here's
goodwin um
regarding chapter 10 how do you not blow
yourself
up too early or too late ooh that's such
a good one who's that from
linkedin user well hello linkedin user
uh fan of all your work
uh the question was if you're gonna make
an existential flex and you have the
courage to make it
and you're willing to blow up ever blow
up the company the question is how do
you know when to blow it up
so you don't blow up too soon that you
hurt yourself but you don't wait too
long that doesn't happen
i mean there you there there's your
answer uh
at some point you gotta jump uh you can
hesitate a little bit
but at some point you're gonna jump and
quite frankly the hardest part
is just making the decision um uh i know
from my own experience
i i tend to err on being just a little
slow i don't mean months
sometimes days or weeks because
sometimes just
waiting a few days just waiting a beat
new information is revealed
sleeping on it a little bit it should
not be an impulsive decision
the realization you can come to the
realization quickly like oh we're going
to have to do this
but don't execute it the next day even
though you're 100 certain it has to
happen
give it a little give it a little beat
and make sure you're talking about it
with the people who are going to help
you do it if you're responsible for the
organization
probably other executives because what
you want to make sure is that you
covered
a few bases and like i said you might
have some new information revealed on
how to do it responsibly
so yes once you come to the mental
realization it has to be done
you don't want to wait too long you just
want to wait a couple beats um
and then the hardest part is pulling the
trigger and just like
like anything that requires a little bit
of courage a bungee jump or jumping out
of a plane with a parachute um the
hardest part is the first step and then
once you've taken the leap it's
it's actually more exciting than your
than you'll then you'll realize so
you're gonna have to make that jump at
some point
sooner rather than later uh let's take
one more question
uh here is kihahan she's 15 years old
from south korea oh my god i love it
oh sorry kia sorry sorry kiha
he is 15 years old uh from south korea
i'm your biggest fan and follower of
your vision thank you i have a question
on behalf of my mom
and my dad is it possible to create
trust between
company and employees when there are
cultural and lifelong
engravings of the notion companies equal
villains and workers equal victims
if so and how would the lifestyle and
systems change be worked on
okay so good and i think unfortunately
this affects a lot of countries this is
a really good question which is
we now view things like government as a
villain
we now view things like companies as
villains
especially public companies um we talk
about you know when you ever the ad
the in front of a a term it becomes sort
of
angry like the corporations corporations
are
the corporations it's sort of filled
with anger right um
and seeing workers as victims how do you
change it well how do you eat an
elephant
one mouthful at a time and and what we
need is this
those few organizations who believe that
it's different
that that believe that organizations
have a responsibility to their people
and what you want is new narratives
coming out of companies the reason
uh workers often see themselves as
victims is because sometimes that's how
they're treated
and so when they go home they go oh
they're beating us up again or they're
taking advantage or they laid us off
again so that the boss can
protect you know their bonus again
right and we see it on the news and we
see ceos
doing they're having their companies
doing a terribly terribly unethical
things
and when forced to defend their actions
they say we we follow the law
right like oh good i'm so proud my mic
the company i work for
follows the law even though they're
highly unethical um and so what it
requires is those leaders to do things
differently
airbnb is a good example there are
things that are happening differently
they're
redefining what business can look like
we're talking what you're talking about
kiha is making
a societal shift what we're talking
about is making
um a systemic and cultural shift
now the fact that the most common
question i get
is i believe in the infinite mindset but
my boss doesn't is a sign that we have
too many finite minded
leaders right now leading organizations
which leads to companies being seen as
villains
and workers feeling like victims the
but the fact that the people asking this
question means this next generation of
leadership
wants to change it and so we want to
empower them we want to keep it going
and it will change um but it's going to
take time it's going to take time
but we have to commit ourselves to that
change how do you get into shape start
going to the gym and eating healthy is
it easy no does it take time yes
you commit yourself to the process and
that's what this whole thing is about
this whole book is about committing
ourselves to a process
with absolute certainty that the process
works if we just
stick to it and the problem is sometimes
the metrics lag
like working out like making friends
like falling in love
like sometimes we don't know what's
going on until
the person says i love you or maybe we
can't even see that we're getting into
shape we keep looking in the mirror and
we see no
we see nothing changing in our bodies
and if we don't have those immediate
reactions we sometimes quit and so a
large part of what this book is about is
committing to the process
of building an infinite mindset knowing
that it is imperfect it is human it is
messy it is difficult
it's going to require help that's what
this is
about um i have to wrap up
i don't want to wrap up i'm having so
much fun um
speaking of committing to that process
um i asked the team to make a class for
our online classes about what it takes
to
live with an infinite mindset so they've
done that
and so we have a new class uh
that is all about what it takes to play
with an infinite mindset which i'm so
proud that we built
reading a book is one step having
conversations is another step and
anything we can do it in part
to help the class is not live yet
but if you want you can go click and
sign up and we'll send you an email
when it does come live i think we're
going to put a link in the chat there
there it is uh it's a complicated link
but anyway
if you go click on the link um
we'll let you know when that class goes
live i'm very excited about that um and
it's one of those things that we're
pivoting to we're like how do we take
the contents of a book and actually make
it more actionable so
very excited about that it's called the
infinite game class that's what it's
called
straight to the point there you go we've
got a bunch of other new classes as well
um start with why for those people who
did the jump start your y
class um hugely popular
and we decided to do two new versions of
them we did we're doing ones
especially for veterans um and we're
doing one especially for health care
professionals we know in this crazy
crazy time
um in healthcare um nice for healthcare
professionals to be
able to reconnect with their why and so
we've been working with um
a trauma nurse uh because she's in the
industry and she's been going through
covet and being a part of it
and she's been working with us to help
us um uh
build this class so if you're a
healthcare professional and want to
learn your why we have a class just for
you
if you're a military veteran who's
transitioning um
and you want to learn your why we have a
class just for you go check it out
at simoncynic.com inspire you um
two other new classes i'm excited about
uh turn adversity into an advantage
again we're trying to produce stuff
that's relevant to now from harvard
professor
laura huang uh uh also getting a lot of
good feedback on that one
and then mindful meditation for focused
leadership from gianna biscantini
jana biscantini is my coach
and uh if uh if you don't know what the
power of meditation is to being a leader
man let me tell you i i have a
meditation practice
gianna helps me she's an amazing coach
um and so she has mindful meditation
specifically for focused leadership
uh what else uh as always you know we
have a secret
book club discount code if you want to
take any of our classes
just type in the discount code book club
rules it's
book club rules to get 20 off any of our
classes as always
and we will be doing another one of
these because i don't want to say
goodbye and i don't want it to end
on august 21st 1 p.m eastern
together is better uh it's available in
most countries
in some countries it has the scented
page
unfortunately not all countries wasn't
my choice but they're
um i don't know where here it is one of
the pages here it is
if you scr if you rub it gently
it smells like optimism and if nothing
else
uh the smell of optimus is really nice
in this day and age
so we're going to read and talk about uh
together is better
in a couple of weeks um
i think that's about it um just a
reminder book club has nothing to do
with
reading a book it's about doing
something together i hope
you keep your book clubs going please
find another book
i can recommend a few if you like but
please continue with your book clubs
maybe one of you will suggest something
and please keep your book clubs going
and have your conversations every week
um because it's really important to do
things together
during these times as always take care
of yourself
take care of each other and i'll see you
real soon see you in two weeks